a massive Southern California wildfire
is threatening more homes this morning
after advancing three miles since
Saturday at 270 thousand acres the
Thomas fire is the third largest
wildfire in modern California history
funeral procession for a firefighter
killed Thursday crossed five counties
first responders saluted as it passed
Carter Evans is in Montecito near Santa
Barbara where multimillion-dollar
estates burned Carter good morning good
morning this is one of nine homes that
burned in the Montecito area with the
break in the winds
firefighters say yesterday was one of
the most productive days they've had on
this two-week old fire there are some
eighty-five hundred firefighters working
right now to stop the flames the Thomas
fire roared back to life over the
weekend as wind gusts hitting 70 miles
per hour
pushed the flames into the wealthy
community of Montecito near Santa
Barbara this is what Sonia biermann's
house looked like on Friday but this is
the devastation she returned to on
Sunday night it's hard let me tell you
we've had our moments it's been crying
until we got here and it's like well
it's kind of flame on Saturday more than
3000 people in and around Montecito were
forced to evacuate these flames are like
three stories high you know they're
they're scary to look at
some 1300 structures in Montecito were
threatened this weekend but firefighters
were able to keep the number damaged or
destroyed 2:15 this is the firestorm
destroyed you saw the firefighters in
Azusa
when that wind was blowing there's not
much you can do there was no there's no
way you could
a fire front like that the fire is now
scorched more than 420 square miles if
it were placed over the New York City
area at more than 40 miles wide it would
reach from New Jersey into Long Island
more than 700 homes have been destroyed
and 18,000 structures are still
threatened the Thomas fire has claimed
two lives including 32 year old
firefighter Corey Iverson who died
Thursday from burns and smoke inhalation
firefighters and other mourners honored
Iverson Sunday by lining the streets for
his funeral procession he's survived by
his pregnant wife and 2 year old
daughter this fire is now 45 percent
contained in mandatory evacuation orders
are still in place but there is almost
no wind right now and that is great news
so firefighters are working fast to get
a containment line all the way around
the fire before the winds are forecast
to return again on Wednesday Gale and
the touch-and-go continues can't say
enough about the job that the
firefighters are doing there thank you
so much Carter